-Here's what people
are talking about.
President Trump
had a very good day.
He's very proud.
Republicans finally passed
his tax bill,
which means Trump's
about to sign his first
major piece of legislation.
Yep, his chest
was puffed out so far,
his tie was actually
at normal length.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Wow.
It's actually at my waist.
Amazing.
Normally, it's down there.
I can actually hold water --
I can drink water with one hand.
I don't feel like tweeting.
I'm a new man."
[ Laughter ]
But Trump was very happy.
He said,
"We are now pouring rocket fuel
into the engine of our economy."
And if you've ever poured rocket
fuel into a regular engine,
you know, it ruins the engine,
but still -- still, I --
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's been
a lot of criticism.
I read that
only 24% of Americans
think the GOP tax plan is good.
To put that in perspective,
the Spice Girls movie
got a 29% on Rotten Tomatoes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I loved it.
-I love it.
-House Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi said
that the tax plan
is an all-out looting of America
and a wholesale robbery
of the middle class.
Which incidentally is also
the slogan for Whole Foods.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It's organic applesauce!"
[ Laughter ]
-$17?
-"It knows three languages."
[ Laughter ]
I'd pay 30 bucks for that.
University of Pennsylvania,
which is Trump's alma mater,
says the tax bill
will add $2.2 trillion
to the national debt.
Trump was like, "Come on.
Are you gonna really believe
a school that let me graduate?
Give me a break, come on."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now all of a sudden..."
And people are still talking
about this Pentagon UFO program.
And Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said that she'd have to check
with the President
to see if he believes in UFOs.
[ Light laughter ]
But she got her answer
when she saw Trump
wearing a tinfoil hat that said
"Make Earth Great Again."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Take me to your leader."
-[ Laughing ]
"Wall-E"
-"Wall-E."
[ Laughter ]
Check this out.
Google says that some of
the years most popular
"how to" searches were "How
to make solar eclipse glasses"
and "How to buy Bitcoin."
-Oh.
-They also released a
least-popular "how to" searches.
These are things that basically
no one searched for all year.
They're pretty interesting.
I'll show you what I mean.
For example,
only three people searched for
"How to find out
if Papa John is single."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Only three people.
-Three people.
-Only two people searched for
"How to watch longer ads
before YouTube videos."
-Oh, wow.
-People want to see more
before their video.
-Yeah, I want the ad
to be longer, too.
-And finally,
only one person searched for
"How to extend my Uber ride
so my driver
can finish his life story."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No, keep talking.
I want to hear more."
You guys, we're just five days
away from Christmas.
That's right, yeah,
you can be excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm psyched.
Five days away.
But did you see this?
Rome's official Christmas tree
is being mocked
because it lost
a lot of its needles.
Did you see the photo?
This is real.
This is from Rome.
Take a look.
Oh, boy, yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Yeah.
Even Charlie Brown was like,
"What the hell is that?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a Christmas tree.
And, finally, I saw that there's
now a NORAD Santa Tracker app,
so you can watch Santa
travel all over the world
on your phone.
Sounds like a great idea
until Mrs. Claus sees
Santa's been at the same house
for over an hour.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We were just talking!"
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!